oh [ __ ]
oh [ __ ] fill up that bowl fill up that
bowl we ain't [ __ ] around today it's
Wednesday
oh [ __ ] is Wednesday [ __ ] the
22nd spring is here who gives a [ __ ]
spring it lives in my nutsack every day
it's Wednesday you're thinking Joey
where's my ship gonna come in when is my
ship gonna come in it's [ __ ] in you
just don't see it [ __ ]
uncle Joey here throwing heat showing up
with a big dick and [ __ ] popsicles
who gives a [ __ ] jack today's your lucky
day
while these [ __ ] over what are
we gonna do the government huh
you got your finger banging Mona Lisa
under her skirt they're looking around
waiting for a [ __ ] 20 and here you
are putting the [ __ ] 90 together
that's how we do it Joey what's with the
chitter chatter we're gonna spark this
[ __ ] number one there you go
in full effect it's 8:47 a.m. have you
hugged your child today I hug her like
10 times that's why I'm out here the
[ __ ] sparking like a soldier getting
my day ready situated 22 push-ups for
the vets protein powder I took a [ __ ]
the toilet top down
I had a [ __ ] get the bigger the
[ __ ] [ __ ] clean and put on eye
level blast and I'm ready for [ __ ]
war got a good night's sleep I'm rested
I got jujitsu I got a meeting we got a
podcast tonight and it's off the [ __ ]
chain it's onward and onward we don't
take a step back we take too forward you
know I'm saying and look the
[ __ ] the angle what [ __ ] it's
my [ __ ] property
like I said it's your world these
[ __ ] are visiting it could be
their world and you could just be
walking through Italy or it could be
your world and they could be walking
through it the choice is yours
[ __ ] you could either do or die
today is the [ __ ] day you're gonna
sit there I'm depressed who gives a [ __ ]
you ain't got time to be the press you
know what depression is being in a
[ __ ] cell with no windows with three
squares and black people yelling next to
you that's depression if you ain't
living that go [ __ ] yourself okay your
cat guy you died your dog got hit bury
that [ __ ] smoked a number pick
up your [ __ ] self and get out there
you ain't got time to be sad I'm feeling
blue here will [ __ ] draw a picture
and get to it [ __ ]
I'm showing up a bit
la competencia I got a bag of weed while
Snoop gave me from a mad scientist named
[ __ ] Zaire that's how we're doing it
today I love you [ __ ] dog you
know I'm saying and then f is enough
enough is enough what are you gonna say
[ __ ] these [ __ ] this is my
world
they gotta suck my dick they gotta come
on my playing field
I don't text you text me the text gets
lost you know why I don't give a [ __ ]
about your text
it's my [ __ ] world pick up the phone
or if not go [ __ ] your mother either
pick up the phone and go [ __ ] your
mother is that simple that's the school
of thought I come from this business
jack you think I'm on [ __ ] social
media look it's a psychiatry [ __ ]
Facebook every morning what's gonna
happen pictures of mom gives a [ __ ] it's
what you make happen they [ __ ] the news
you got to make your own news you if I'm
saying the eyeballs are on fire today
anyway next week Nyack New York the old
Cuckoo's Nest up there I'm coming back
home it's all over but the [ __ ]
roller skating you understand me on top
of that when you watch High Court you
see I don't [ __ ] around but on [ __ ]
smokes the size of you know listen if
you're not gonna be a professional stay
at Starbucks and drink a macchiato with
almond milk to some [ __ ] go lie to your
friends some day will come we'll walk
the mountains of who gives a [ __ ] you
gotta walk the mountains of [ __ ] the
streets of your [ __ ] neighborhood you
gotta walk everybody wants to take a
[ __ ] trip and do what and do what the
only trip you gotta take is covering
your back and slinging dick that's your
[ __ ] mission on a daily once you got
[ __ ] with 29 chicks rubbing your toes
and somebody fart in your face and you
count [ __ ] 20s as you're doing it
that's when you stop [ __ ] around
until then oh yeah they didn't get my
might Filipino I look at por la fin de
lins go holla
you know what that means through my dick
you gonna have to shoot me cops
I shout out the immigrants don't be down
today the immigration keep your head up
and keep walking straight you know I'm
saying [ __ ] it don't give in
run to the end like Harrison Ford grow a
beard do what you got to do young Sam
beside that Churchill was happening now
eight o'clock Nyack New York next
Thursday night we're gonna [ __ ] it up
all right we're gonna [ __ ] it up and
June and D ow
my main [ __ ] man up there the
connection up in Nyack you got big
[ __ ] days today you understand me of
my man Tommy used to sling it [ __ ]
dick in Hollywood we got [ __ ]
Confederates everywhere anyway I have a
good day I'm a little [ __ ] up but I'm
straight up and that's all right that's
it that's all you need to [ __ ] though
you know I got a couple felonies yeah I
did a couple fucked-up things but my
heart's in the right place and that's
all that matters
you turn on the news for 15 minutes you
see all these people these [ __ ]
takes 22 of them to make a decision you
understand you makes a decision in your
world you you grab your nutsack you
smoke a bowl you think about it for two
seconds and you make you [ __ ] move
you understand me it ends today I don't
listen you read whatever the [ __ ] you
want you don't need to read nothing you
open up a notebook and today and you're
right today is my day ain't nobody gonna
[ __ ] with me today see what happens all
right I'll see you [ __ ] tonight
eight o'clock but they don't be late
don't [ __ ] with me all right 15 minutes
before I pay your professional if they
get there late you just eyeball and say
who's running this [ __ ] day today huh
I love you [ __ ] I act Allah would
decide time with their ire book mm I
mean see Camaro carbine that means my
big snores it's got sleep apnea it's got
problems anyway I love you
they go for it go for it that's it